okay so I think this live stream has
taken off I hope it really does I've
started a couple of minutes before the
actual starting time to see if it
actually works
yeah I've got I have got it set up here
with the leeches aside we agreed to play
on but um the whole YouTube streaming
thing is not what I'm doing regularly so
I hope it works all right you can give
me some feedback it would be nice if you
hear and see everything all right I'm
probably going to adjust the view on the
leech s side a little bit once we have
got to the actual match started I don't
know how big the board is so once we
start to play so I am kept it like this
and I'm going to change it once um we
have started so if you can give me some
feedback on the quality it would be very
nice okay yeah playing Grand Master Todd
Baron I'm going to pronounce it in
English style now yeah it's a very
promising player from Israel Israeli
2,560 so very good Grandmaster and if I
understood correctly is also currently
um yeah training a training camp to play
for Israel at the upcoming Olympiad so I
have my hands full here
yeah and hope it works all right yeah if
you've got any questions to ask we've
got five minutes five minutes until the
start there's also going to be
on the channel okay and you cannot
really do much against some some morons
in the shed who do actually ban people I
have no idea how to do that I am I can
block users
hmm yeah I hope I blocked him all right
we'll see what happens
very few people have the patient of
constantly posting [ __ ] messages in
a chat yeah I'm looking forward to this
match currently not being in the best of
shape sand in the Blitz games but it
will definitely improve and maybe this
match is an opportunity to get some to
get back into stride let's say okay so I
know that Tallis also around like three
minutes till the start I should bring up
Westco over there okay so I'm basically
ready to roll the question what's this
match announced yes sir but it was just
like two hours ago match is going to
starting in about three three minutes or
two minutes something like that I only
wanted to check the general technical
side of things that is why I started a
couple of minutes earlier
I don't stream that often so I'm wanted
to be be sure that it actually works
singing a song I don't think you want
that
okay yeah probably will play the English
opening I have not prepared for the
match I have to say I have no idea what
tom is playing I know he's a
earlier default player with white
because he beat me in one synonyms oh
yeah we'll see what happens I really
don't put much preparation into into
matches like this I've never prepared
for any of those matches I just think
it's it's supposed to be a yeah
entertaining and also maybe a good
that's the odd moment offer of
instructional advice okay yeah okay
taught us in the chat very nice I think
he probably handles the technical side
here better than I do
yeah channel is also broadcasting in the
description of this livestream there is
a link to his livestream you can also go
I think and via his channel so there
should be more than one way of of
getting them
yep how much money is my book um it
depends it should be roughly 20 euros if
you purchase it from a book dealer I
don't offer sales on myself anymore
I've sold everything that I had oh it
says yeah yeah it's possible
probably have to tweak my settings game
behavior no game display it's probably
here yes that challenge always yep all
good
okay so I had challenges off somehow so
we should challenge me any minute I just
have to adjust the string a little bit I
hope to get the wort I get the board I
don't see the challenge yet
it maybe that's a there's a deal on the
book that's possible I don't follow that
getting where is the challenge there is
a chance I'm going to accept it and now
I have to quickly adjust this screen
capture so that the actual board is a
bit bigger see if we can do that maybe
like this okay so let's get going so
I've got got black in the first game and
I told him that I needed a second to me
to adjust
so let's get going
this is the first game and yep I have
some ideas here playing on banku okay he
declines it anyway just choose six no he
takes it okay hmm
yeah this is a way to do it so get the
declined bank oh I think I can still
take this later I don't think it's very
time critical to take this pawn
maybe now see going 92 I would like to
play Bishop g4
yeah it's putting it on c4 it's probably
a good idea okay for I don't want to go
85 this is definitely not a good idea
I can't let's go back just one or two
things yeah that's not idea but okay
there should be you should know how the
match score is yeah Quinn be seven is a
bit of a strange move but I don't know
that line at all him Todd is also
streaming it the the his the link is in
the description to the stream trying to
play Bishop to b5 the bishop is always
very stupid looking piece so I'm trying
to get it to be five
now you can also watch his stream as
mansion is a it's in the description but
both of the streams will be on YouTube
later so it's going to be an easy to
follow both sides we play five plus two
so five minutes and a two-second
increment we agreed on that because we
thought that this is probably going to
be helpful with the quality of the games
so let's see okay I'm happy with the
line with the bishop on b5 so does this
piece is going to be exchanged
that's generally important in those Ben
Oni kind of structures to get to get
something traded let's see what he wants
to do here I like my position this is
not so bad
yeah tried the bank oh I think I'm not
sure if he really prepares for for this
kind of events and but I know he we had
an image of game and he's a big fan of
the f3 names Oh so um I didn't really
fancy acontece them I like this for
black I've got it end up in my book but
I didn't really have time to refresh my
memory there I know that he beat him
that that he beat me pretty convincingly
in one of the ICC blitz game so it's
something okay let's take now I'm ready
for night to be five maybe it's got a 5
in the mix but I can take d5 and there's
an IP 5 and I have a huge time advantage
in quite surprisingly it seems that
seems that is not so much at home here
if I've so move that feels somewhat
critical to me oh that's interesting so
he allows me to go there with the big
tempo okay not to deform okay but okay
so he always has not to be 6e am
hmm okay that cannot be bad
I mean how to believe that this is bad
might come into be six a bit of an
annoyance there we'll see what happens
hmm
okay queen bee five he cannot he
actually can establish this one B six
but still it looks like a good move I
think
maybe it's putting the night back ok he
did that
I can also go to b3 intending Quincy -
yeah
twins trade it would be nice I think I
had to announcement videos on one for
the regular stream and this one yeah I
know
both those on Monday is a bit difficult
but Tuesday Wednesday doesn't work I
mean there is a Nakamura and Greece
shocks match on and so on it was a bit
too much I think to do it on the same
day okay so what's this I can take twice
only five hmm yeah but it opens up for
all kinds of stuff I still have to not
take so let's grab it
yeah maybe he's got some hook f7 does he
have that that would be very weird and
not very weird but would be kind of
surprising I think if if such tactic
would would be on okay so here he's
attacking me five okay and he may might
move the knight but I don't really see
where f6 s may be possible let's do have
six keep the bishop on e5 Oh Queen h4
actually should have calculated a little
bit down that's also move C going 495
there maybe anyway I have to take it
95 Queen c2 I have to play 97 he's got
stuff going on down hmm definitely
dangerous maybe go back
yeah this is going to be very dangerous
if I take it take night takes but is
that really working takes Knight takes
it doesn't have a check at the end
esquinas finish for Jackie ass hmm I
don't really have a good way to decline
this I think look at 7:00 night the
Queen takes Knight takes Queen takes Wow
okay so yeah it's that so it tricked me
here on what probably yes look eight
seven
what a mess
at the end he's taking d6
you're threatening night at six years
the problem I have to do this
unfortunately
this is made in tool
so probably wrong okay pull that handle
didn't it had ended in a draw it was a
tough game okay it's just this here
right right so we have a tied score
looks a bit stranger yeah I should put
bleach s I cannot do that now okay so
it's 0.5 0.5 and where is the rematch
button this rematch let's go for the
second game
yeah that's was an up and up and down
struggle I was certainly winning at one
point and he probably also was winning
at some point so maybe a draw isn't
totally off so yeah I used lots of time
they're putting himself into a tricky
situation
yeah a symmetrical English this is
something reasonably solid
okay I'm surprised that he that he
allows us early before him
okay so b5 no
c3 is uncovered but I don't think it
okay interesting so he basically he
wants to sacrifice him can I not just
take the spawn why not I don't know
okay maybe just goes rupee age'
that's possible but it's hard to not
take yeah probably he gets it back with
rugby ain't yeah maybe maybe I should
have played b5 myself
yeah I looked at those books by Colson
and marine but well I just did my own
stuff my experience with those um using
using all the books for own owns own
things own work you can look at them but
I think I'd rather do my own things also
I mean in III got a went form different
lines for that repertoire then coastal
and marine did some are some are
identical but most of them are not I
wonder if he has something Queen b6 I go
back 94 you know and he is attacking on
f2 and is attacking my knight this kind
of tactic he could be well be working
I'm sorry I should have checked this
maybe maybe I have to go to a three year
the child should be streaming this
stream is not public I cannot really
tell you what's going on and he takes a
Aegis yeah what's going on okay you went
to hook v8 so I should be able to go
Knight c3 him now now that wasn't very
successful I probably should have played
b5 earlier I can probably just play m9
takes before
Wow he's really taking his time I mean I
totally dislike people blitzing out
everything instantly but he takes long
things in the opening to an extreme okay
so I'm just taking this and Bishop d2 I
just developed normally yeah this is of
course equal on this position but didn't
really work out my opening anyway but
it's equal nothing nothing particularly
dangerous going to happen I believe so
can we nee for here yeah
where is he going back to a6 or
something let's be quick here
I am okay hmm
cream b5 it's it's really just equal I
guess mm-hmm I wonder maybe just Knight
f3 right he doesn't have any discovery
an idea for I can cancel Bishop d7 might
be Bishop d7 is actually a little bit
annoying the Bishop d7 I don't I don't
have a very good very good move away in
a ball I don't have Queen b3 this is the
thing after Bishop d7
- Bishop d7 I don't have a good move
only 21 I see and this is not great not
great
hmm I can go Queen b5 but I don't like
that getting very far behind in
development they do it I don't really
like the other stuff either
yeah that's five plus two
sorry for the weird sound to have
something running in the kitchen yeah so
what now I don't like my position this
Bishop d7 this is quite annoying that
he's got he's got net seat also
shouldn't really be in danger out of
this opening but somehow I managed
94 is a somewhat technical solution but
it looks strange maybe it's good though
my dad 3 Bishop d7 sucks I don't know I
don't like this but the other things are
also weird as I'm stupid him we can we
can do this and I have to have to take
on c2 which is clearly ridiculous
looking down oh my I totally screwed
this game up totally totally oh that's
very embarrassing game yeah I didn't
like all that Queen twin b5 was
immediate move but I didn't really see
anything good yeah now I have this
absolutely bad position I cannot move
the knight
hmm
I think I have to resign this it's too
bad
now I totally screwed this opening up I
have to check this ready it should be
pretty equal ish but maybe Queen 84 was
a bad idea I don't know I should just
develop maybe this Queen b6 Bishop d7 is
very strong okay anyway let's see that
to get a rematch going just meshed so
he's leading mm-hmm yeah the ratings are
really really funny I'm a huge rating
underdog I don't think the actual
playing strength difference is that
great but it would seem so he's going in
for oh my I didn't even know that he
plays that okay so do we have okay
watching coming up with this one okay
somehow I thought about that it could be
this is something that he could blame
I don't know if he sometimes places
before entitlements yes I have no idea
maybe he doesn't like the bank Oh
yeah so we got a mainline Dutch there I
actually don't need to put this core
stuff unless a squad under underneath
that the bottom of the screen
I just screen I just saw that yeah I'm
not so well accustomed to leeches so I
didn't know that there is as this on
okay at some point you have to take on
the foe I don't know if this point is
reached hmm probably have to put this
back at some point anyway
this is a very complicated position type
I always think that this is interesting
for white players to try simply because
it is not so well known and can lead to
interesting play
mmm if I go c4 takes my eggs isn't
something taking his bishop it's a very
weird way of playing and probably not
taking on a phone I don't know
hmm yeah beef is under check I don't
really like to take but see for also
looks wrong mmm
I have g5 maybe I can take and play d5
in this position but that would be
interesting d5 d3 is unprotected so
let's do it let's do it
yeah so one going back to see Asian the
issue here might might well be that the
position opens up and he's a little bit
better coordinated that could be but I'm
not sure about it the night on c8 looks
weird but it might have a good I don't
think I can change the stream title to
leeches no I think it's too late
it's a bit difficult also that during
this during the game playing doing this
during the game I'm not really sure if I
can do this and I could try actually
okay I changed the title I think I think
I did okay so here I'm going see form
I hope you ain't threatening c3
threatening c3 okay it goes back yes so
what now Bishop before again would put
the thread up takes takes not sure about
it
96 doesn't work
and I can still do this threatenings g3
takes c3 bishop g6 I can take on g2
I changed the title totally chess walk
in it would be cool it would be feature
I think it's a cool match so I have to
score here right probably after losing
that terrible game with white maybe he
can play takes c3 takes on c3 hmm I
don't think so we play the fruit first
to have four points rook c3 ok so it's
getting messy it's getting messy what's
happening here Knight to g6 maybe takes
the droop c3 takes and c3 again let's do
it
maybe he can go if I but then I have
might be 5 this is just strategically
okay I think yeah this should be just a
good position from a strategic point of
view after night to b5 um or Knight f5
Knight f5 also makes some sense actually
if he moves through I have C 3
probably institutions and it should be
also quite nice I have the pestle and I
have not have a to e6 if five is hanging
so I don't know if I want to take that
pawn actually I want to brother bring
the knight to e6 right e6f 43 would be
cool
remember that'sthat's really okay
no mind if he takes it yeah after I
insert age six year give me some lift
yeah I can draw thanks the boy and I
actually I know that but if you don't do
it regularly it's not so easy to to do
in a real match situation so um here
there should be four is a move by one I
also want to enter I want to enter if
possible
rookie 7b so
so he wants to put one on our an f5 okay
that's that's nice played this nicely
getting the night down how do I go about
this
okay so injured he dropped it back this
is not not that aggressive looking at
least so Queen to see 743 this is a
threat c3 is something that he has to
attend to
again trying for c3 n soon what is he
playing I won't do months and we need to
there okay so I cannot go c3 right away
it doesn't have a threat at the moment I
don't see a threat Queen to have three
main method I don't think that is that
dangerous
maybe okay I'm going to take one off and
no aim for Game one
I came defend it against that c2 is
going back screwing for Queen of three I
guess
I can do Queen never three oh I didn't
see that one
no I'm losing on time I'm just betting
of course the Queen age five I'm just I
didn't really see the time there should
be some warning anyway this is this is
bad I have to clean age five I'm just
kidding better yeah anyway okay so let's
update the score wow I'm really not
doing it the easy way
I mean it was worse than organum okay so
let's do where'sa rematch
there was no raise no rematch for some
reason I don't know I said didn't see
any time warning or what I don't know
probably about setting but I didn't I
didn't really I didn't really understand
that I was so low on time I mean I was
ahead on time the whole time
I didn't really realize the warning
sound hiss sorry but there probably is
one but I didn't right I didn't
recognize it's not about this sign I
mean I should know my time so it's not a
big deal anyway
but if you are better the whole game you
know you want to win okay it's playing
the same stuff again which i think is
just bad but now I'm playing it I think
better don't allow b5 again I mean it's
not bad as in terrible for black but
that cannot be the solution to this
opening yeah it's this place below the
board but once I started to put a score
I'm going to mean going to maintain it
yeah I was also feeling very secure
because he was burning time like no
tomorrow I did not really have an eye on
that
hi Joe he takes his time Jen yeah what
to say about this match I lost this game
too pretty terribly a game three I was
winning lost some time hmm yeah tough
now could have been easily an even score
98
okay I'm not going to spend a million
minutes like he does really think this
is a bit to be too much I went out of 96
also this is increment I have to keep
that in mind I like to play with the
increment but simply don't do it that
often so thank you
that looks like an excellent position
for white Oh am i overlooking some weird
tactic here
I have Bishop f4 killing 95 coming yeah
what is he doing him Knight c4 or
something for Queen a5 don't know
d6 okay so 95 she's going back to the
8th we had a move that it's interesting
this Bishop f4 bit this is very very
complicated so 95 is kind of normal here
28 John I'd be 6 doesn't lead to much
night b5 is also possible and then take
on d6 but this doesn't really help me
that much
Bishop g5 is also interesting trying to
play 95
my development is not good this is what
I don't like about this it's not good at
all Bishop g5
maybe he just goes f6 looks looks weird
but maybe he has to
that's difficult him taking that doesn't
do doesn't do much might be six again it
uses a lot of time
I don't like the timeliness and all that
very difficult position and take here
mm-hmm
again my time not the time spent but I
lose so much time here with my pieces I
don't like it that much so I think I
should do this now he does I have a
check I just take on c8 and play night
as three to Castle I need to need to get
out here from from the middle
okay I'm strong move I guess I can still
take castle next took me a long time to
get to castling maybe Yuki eight is a
good move trying to prevent it is 326
stuff like that
that's a similarly similarly focused
move
interesting here I'm taking this castle
it's probably equal
see going look a one here I can't
it's not it doesn't have squares I'm to
be a bishop before I know we could have
fire
and this is this is looking very dry
maybe this and Bishop a4 mm-hmm three
before and I cannot just make it wrong I
mean I I have to try
it's not easy for black f7 is still weak
so it's the way to take this now how do
I take it 96 96 King t6 now what did I
take before the so cannot move the
bishop that said so that was a real
decision actually not a good decision
okay
it's still pretty pretty difficult for
him
how'd you get down I cannot get the King
to b3 that would be nice nice to get
mmm how'd you do this yeah I don't see a
win
maybe you just made my way around a
little bit how to get denied to take
this pawn I cannot get the king here
this is the thing
that's a good move
high swing well this guy what can you do
another five muster cheek very well
played
I cannot take you probably have to do
the drawing him I don't see how I can
play for win it's the wrong porn so I
should make it wrong
I think I should
now this is not that this is not a
stalemate
oh my god oh my god I'm gifting so many
points it's crazy not anyway okay so
okay three and a half from a position
that I should know right okay I try to
win and it didn't work out so let's see
him and I have to oh so stupid
pretty stupid not sure it is still a
draw maybe it is but but yeah this
position was really close to winning of
course for Wyatt but couldn't couldn't
find a way so now I absolutely have to
have to score
so maybe I'm luckier this game will this
kind of stuff
yeah this kind of this kind of opening
yeah it's not that bad okay David see if
I can get something on the queenside
it's always good before coming up and if
I've before it's not working here
yeah so what about some counterplay if I
take night h5b should be 3/5 something
like that I need to do something along
these lines
okay so I can probably cancel
you know not a good score I mean I'm I
really I really should have scored a lot
more but um that's the way it goes
sometimes
the do you play more enterprising
justice would like when you're down the
score like this yeah I mean I played the
Bangko in the game and had a good
position with it
this is this is pretty aggressive okay
chair maybe he's better here possible
h4 Kim don't really don't really
understand the move
what's the point
okay if I go before it's playing night
hm I keep going either forward something
that I can do anyway
I need to prepare a group to be aides
something like that
okay so he wants to go to d5 I guess but
this is night okay let's do it I mean
I'm I'm so much down in the match so
might as well try something enterprising
him maybe just place 95 yeah 97 is the
threat I have to take now a 92 s 97
immediately this is a big problem
okay that looks bad
I can just grab a pawn therefore for
nothing in particular at least I don't
see any compensation but it's again
burning time
I see not just taking her for I don't
understand that maybe Knight c3 to
attack b5 maybe that's stronger that's
possible 92 to c3
I cannot easily cover b5 I could that
that sir that's an option
also there c7 okay I understand you can
actually think about this position but
you have it still so I know he takes it
yeah so I'm the spawn one probably party
fire phone
night before okay it's got Bishop to d6
coming okay it's it's an option
95 again or something I know I get any
four hangs actually so it's going 45
yeah I guess I can always come to d5
this is extremely annoying
hmm nice playing a strong game you
cannot cover seven anymore
I don't like this bishop f8 coming
it's not much they cannot do much she
unfortunately
I can take it you can take it damn it I
didn't see that this gives him to be
three square now we're going to lose
that one again crazy that's crazy
I'm not losing so I'm drawing this
catalyst pool okay there he's got four
points right he's good for points and we
played two for it so I think he's won
the match wasn't really that much you
may have it okay so that's a 4-1 and win
form for tau okay guys this is a was a
closer man it was a shorter match than I
expected I hope I hope them to put up a
better fight Congrats to charger it he
came he played very well and yeah I
shouldn't shouldn't have lost 4-1 maybe
like 4 2 or something at least one I
should have won we're lost on time I
didn't really see the time yeah still it
was a very deserved victory for my
opponent I hope you I hope you enjoyed
the coverage I try to do more on those I
think it's always good fun ok guys I
hope you enjoyed it I'm going to be live
again in a little bit under two hours
and we'll be we'll be back then for my
regular on Monday show bye bye guys
until roughly two hours